action  i think like any idea for sequel it came  from a place of trying to surprise  ourselves in the audience when you think  of making a hollywood movie you think of  big explosions big stunts and we had it  it makes for very interesting and  unpredictable stories when no one is a  good guy  the house had to kind of give you all  these little environments which then you  can kind of box people into and lock  them into and fill it with water or burn  it  stephen lang is like a total  professional he just nails it  it was brutal you don't want to hurt  anybody you don't want to get hurt  yourself but it's very rewarding  we gather the best people at the top of  their game they made it look amazing  now you're gonna see what i see  you